so if you're gonna see Black Panther
once it comes out in just a few days on
February 16th and you're wondering who
the villain in the movie is here's a
super quick video telling you everything
you need to know about kill monger
here's where kill mongers story starts
remember this guy Klaw from Avengers age
of Ultron he's the one that Ultron goes
to to get vibranium from and cuts off
his arm when Klaw calls him iron man
well Klaw came to Wakanda and search of
vibranium and ended up forcing kill
mongers parents to help him battle the
wakandans at which kill mongers parents
are killed in battle
after the battle T'Challa banishes kill
manga from Wakanda and kill monger goes
to New York which is where his hatred
for T'Challa and what kinda starts in
New York when Black Panther fights with
the Avengers kill monger meets up with
Black Panther and tells him how he wants
to go back to his homeland and Black
Panther grants the OK on it when he
returns to Wakanda and while T'Challa is
still out fighting with the Avengers he
begins his plot to overthrow two chala
and take the throne as king and black
panther staging an uprising in which
kill monger and black panther fight at
warrior falls which is a scene that
we'll see in the movie so I won't spoil
it
kill monger is a major threat to Black
Panther and the comics come hunger
defeats Black Panther practically every
time and the many fights that they have
the only reason Black Panther was able
to survive the last fight they had is
because someone came and helped Black
Panther by kicking Co mugger off of a
waterfall right before kill monger was
about to kill him
not only does he defeat Black Panther in
many battles he also defeats him with
great ease if you watch my last video on
Black Panther you know that this is
super impressive giving that to chala
himself is a master fighter being a
master of unarmed and armed combat just
like Black Panther is extremely smart
kill monger is super smart as well
holding multiple degrees including a
couple PhDs and an MBA he also manages
to get his hands on a synthetic
heart-shaped herb the real heart shape
herb is what Black Panther eats to gain
superhuman abilities such as increased
speed strength reflexes
senses and the ability to heal rapidly
so basically kill monger has the same
superhuman abilities as Black Panther in
Wakanda you can only partake of the
heart shape herb by passing certain
trials and earning the title Black
Panther which is why kill monger gets
on a synthetic one we also see in the
trailer that kill monger has his own
black panther suit which I'm excited to
see how he gets in the movie Erik kill
mugger is basically the anti black
panther he is just a smart and just a
skilled if not more skilled than Black
Panther in combat and strategic battling
he also has a spotted leopard named prey
that he can call on to help him fight
not sure how much we're gonna see of him
in the movie but still it's pretty cool
so that's everything you need to know
about kill monger it's been rumored that
kill monger is one of the best Marvel
villains to be displayed on screen in
the movies and I can't wait to see Black
Panther and see how the storyline plays
out let me know how you think the
storyline will pan out and if you go see
it this weekend let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below I
hope you enjoyed this brief video and
give it a thumbs up and be sure to
subscribe to my channel for everything
black panther Marvel and superhero thank
you so much for watching and have a
great day